pharmaceutical company Pfizer has
announced it as blocking the use of its
drugs for lethal injections in the
United States the move means that all
approved drug makers whose medications
could be used for executions have now
put them off-limits mark George is a
barrister specializes in criminal and
prison law human rights and us death
penalty law he joins us live from their
Sheffield a very good evening to you
thanks for joining us in at Sky News
your reaction to the news that this step
that Pfizer has now taken well it's a
very welcome announcement it does throw
the death penalty in the u.s. into
renewed crisis and I hope that those
states that still have the death penalty
will actually take this as an
opportunity to really consider whether
it's time for the United States to come
into the 21st century and get rid of
what is a medieval and rather barbaric
practice we've heard from the human
rights organizations were throughout
today who say that this is a critical
turning point in in the history of fur
capital punishment in the United States
is that your assessment yeah well I it's
always difficult I think then perhaps a
little dangerous to make those sorts of
assessments at a time like this
the fact is that there are some states
in the u.s. that are still very
enthusiastic about enforcing the death
penalty so we shouldn't underestimate
the determination of some states places
like Texas and Missouri and Oklahoma to
continue to try to find ways to carry on
executions and as you say there are some
states who were very keen to at least
have the power to be able to enforce the
death penalty there will be some people
who argue well hang on a minute why
should be big business be playing a part
be flexing its muscles which will
affecting our legislative system what
what's it got to do with them well these
are pharmaceutical companies and they
produce medicines and so on because they
believe that they're going to be used
for the benefit of mankind and not
surprisingly they're not very keen on
the adverse publicity from discovering
that drugs they thought were being
produced for beneficial purposes of them
being used to execute people so they are
entitled to be involved and concerned
about it because it does affect their
own business capital punishment was
legally affirmed in the United States in
the early 1970s so it's been going on
for some time now in a number of states
now in the United States do you foresee
a time where capital punishment will be
a thing of the past yes I do
it's taking a long time to eradicate but
in the last eight years seven states
have themselves abolished the death
penalty so that now 19 states in the
Union do not have the death penalty one
of the key changes that's happened in
recent years is that all states now have
as the only alternative to the death
penalty life without parole and there's
clear evidence now from poll data that
shows that when jurors know that the
oniel know that there is an alternative
of life without parole in other words
the person will never be released that
juries are much more likely now to vote
for a life sentence than for death and
we have seen a huge drop in new death
sentences two years ago there were 300 E
last year there were under 50 so it's
quite clear that people on the ground in
the United States are voting to to get
rid of the death penalty so I do think
it will happen but like many of these
things it takes longer than we'd hoped
mr. George are you concerned at all that
some states say Texas for example will
just look for alternative methods or for
executions or look for alternative
lethal compounds from elsewhere very
much so the the desire of some states to
carry on with lethal injections has led
to some very dubious practices a number
of states of passed legislation
preventing even the prisoners own
lawyers from discovering what the nature
of the drugs being used in the
executions is it's obviously a very
unfortunate development because what
you're seeing is effectively live
experimentation on human beings whilst
those who are immersing the death
penalty try various compounds of drugs
or different amounts of drugs and
frankly before they carry out the
execution they don't know what the
effect of those drugs will be okay mark
George barrister thanks for joining this
evening on Earth's sky news pleasure
thank you
this is Sky News coming up